[Musique]
c'est une très bonne question
je pense que tu pourrais avoir raison
[Musique]
inscrit
je pense que l'
opinion publique est outrée pourquoi
euh
[Musique]
mais comme je dis une opinion
tourne avant noël
hey
ce qui va se passer c'est que si 54
membres de
la deuxième question n'oubliez pas d'
envoyer une lettre au chat
il est à la fois le premier ministre et le
chef de la
[Musique]
euh
non je pense qu'il est crédité pour
la personne qui est maintenant le
ministre de l'éducation bien sûr
par exemple a
commencé le euh booster  campagne en
particulier
avant que
nous
[Musique] les
gens n'en veuillent pas
qui suggère que lui et son entourage
sont au-dessus du seigneur
[Musique]
étranger